foreign
let's go back to Tejas and talk to
Samantha what's up Samantha
hello
hello
how are we doing going excellent I'm
good and you
yes I'm good very cool what's up
okay so my original question has changed
a little bit okay
um I sent that question on a really
rough day and I've since then had a
really great conversation with my
husband walk me through your original
question
okay so it was basically asking for
practical tips on how to trust my
husband after a pornography addiction
okay all right
um and that problem solved
um sort of I mean it's not like solved
sure excellent all right so on to the
next question what's the next question
okay
so
um so basically I still okay so it's
been about a year and a half since he's
been clean from looking at anything okay
um and so but I still struggle with my
body image and so I'm kind of looking
for like tips or suggestions on how to
deal with that or increase positivity
with that
um and then I also
um just wanted to mention that I feel
like spent all of it happened I've kind
of lost
um it's been more than a year and a half
since it came out and there was also
some like from when we dated and so it's
been like years
um of kind of struggling with this off
and on
um
so I I feel like somewhere along the way
I lost like the fun part of me
and I feel like it probably has to do
with that
um and I don't really know how to get
that back
um
so I know that's a lot but whatever we
get to is fine it'll all be beneficial
no that's good I
um
let me see here
so this is a hard conversation to have
and here's why
um the only
part of the conversation I can have is
with you because he's not here okay and
what makes this a challenge is
I can I can tell you some hard truths
um but I want you to acknowledge that
I'm telling you this stuff because I
love you and not because and I care
about you and your marriage not because
I'm just piling on
it's gonna feel like a pile on when
you're listening because I'd only have
if he was here too I'd be piling on him
right does that make sense it's not like
I'm picking one over the other so I only
got one here right
um so that's that frames this walk me
through your history so I want to take
him and put him in a box in a drawer and
close the drawer okay
box closed
when did your body
when did you not like what you saw in a
mirror begin
um
um I don't know sophomore year of
college I didn't get the Freshman 15 I
got the sophomore 15.
um so I kind of around that time this is
before that um I'd be willing to bet my
truck's not very nice but I wouldn't be
willing to bet my car this is not about
15 pounds gained your sophomore year
college and you were 19 and 20 years old
that's correct when did the story that
you didn't look right to begin
who told you
I don't I don't know that anybody told
me that I am currently reading your
newest book um and so I know there's
like questions in there about
um like was your
family like always on a diet and always
talking about weight and stuff like that
and that is true for me but it wasn't
directed at me it was mostly like my dad
so listen that was always that well so I
said that mean like so listen I didn't
mean to say it like that
um
children absorb their environment in a
Mainline fashion
yeah okay so I am working with a guy
um
I'm losing weight but not because I
quote unquote need to lose weight I'm
trying to accomplish a particular thing
and so I'm working with one of the top
guys in the in the country on this
and I'm also trying to dial in my
nutrition so I'm partnering with
Dr Norton's helping right so I'm I'm
talking
I have zero issues with my aesthetic
okay
my son who's 12
I saw him grabbing parts of his belly
the other day
and he's a cross-country stud he's very
thin and he started asking questions and
I was like whoa whoa whoa we're cutting
this off right now
okay
because he picks up what's in the air
and Main lines it as though this is him
okay so whether somebody and this is
important I whether somebody said you're
gonna look pretty
or you're overweight which is common
right that people are kids are told that
all the time
or you are conscious constantly around
people who are always looking in the
mirror saying I don't look good enough I
need to do this we can't go out here
I've got to eat this because I can't do
this I've got to do that because I can't
do this
that that's just what's modeled for you
as you better be careful about what you
look like because that has a direct
correlation to how much and how well and
how deep you're loved
okay and so in if you if you you mean
I've got there been in the book we talk
about there's stories that you were told
but there's also stories you're born
into
and that 15 pounds may have and I again
I don't want to harp on that because I
think that may be too simplistic but
it may set off a Cascade of
stress response chemicals in your body
that's sounding and start sending alarms
saying you're not enough well look out
look out look out look out
and then your body begins scanning the
environment for places where you're not
beautiful
places where you're not seeing places
where you're not loved you see what I'm
saying
and then knucklehead
sets off those alarms he sets off a
wildfire with gasoline right yeah how
did you stumble into his pornography
addiction
um which time yep so I mean there's like
three different times okay
um so twice when we were dating and then
a third time after we were married
um so the first time was uh a
conversation we were having we were
driving
and he kind of like was testing the
waters and seeing like what my reaction
would be and so he asked like so I've
known that he like struggled with it in
the past
um and so he kind of like tested the
waters by asking like what would you do
or what would you say if blah blah blah
blah that's the most 19 year old way to
introduce like so let's pretend well
yeah you walked in and so anyway yeah
yeah okay so yeah here's the thing so
you stumbled you all had conversations
about it which led to another
conversation and so and then here it is
right so let's again let's put him back
in the box and back in the door
when it comes to quote-unquote body
positivity
at the end of the day
I wish it was different than what I'm
about to say
but you're going to have to make a
choice
to look in the mirror and decide
I have value
before and Beyond
Aesthetics before external beauty
I am lovable I am worth being loved
and from the inside out
the words that I say have value and
meaning the things that I think are
funny are actually funny
the people I like being with are
actually people worth being with
and from that inside out
you then take on a stewardship I'm a
person who stewards their body
I'm a person who takes care of myself
because I'm a person of value it has to
work that direction you can never lose
enough weight to make the inside of
yourself feel okay
yeah right it's like you can't ever earn
enough money to make yourself feel
valuable
you can buy a lot of a lot of solutions
to problems but you can't solve that
inner gnawing right and so when you
start and again you and I can sit down
for a couple hours and probably peel
back a ton of layers on this onion
you have to decide
and choose I am worth these things
and then you've got to look at your
environment
and it may be that your husband Cuts you
off every time you have an idea or he
rolls his eyes and goes we're not going
that way or I don't like that Maybe not
maybe he's wonderful
but often body positivity I have found
is to link directly to
the strength and power of my voice
okay in relationship am I hit am I
hitting Homer at all or no
yeah someone yeah
um I mean definitely making a choice to
decide that I have value before
and Beyond what I look like okay and I
also and this is I don't be
controversial but there's a balance
right there's also I have to look in the
mirror when I got up to 217 pounds if
you like I wasn't healthy
yeah right and so I knew not that I'm
not lovable
and not that I'm wholly unattractive
but I knew that I wasn't I wasn't doing
the best for my body and if I don't do
the best for my body I get grumpy and I
get achy and I just want to watch TV
instead of go play with my kids and I
get
self-conscious and let's don't go to the
pool let's don't go to the lake unless
let's just sit at home right so it has
this down it has this ripple effect all
through everything right yeah and so
again that's inside out
and then the stewardship part is well
then cool I'm just going to start taking
care of my diet I'm gonna start taking
care of moving my body and then my body
responds in time
but again that's all secondary and third
and fourth to the inner stuff which is
I'm worth getting up and exercising I'm
worth taking care of myself and the body
positivity comes from the inside out the
second part of this is I don't think
you've gone all in with with this guy
oh can I ask why yeah or like how
um
you're either waiting for another shoe
to drop
or you are still lining yourself up in
this imaginary line of imaginary women
and putting yourself number 76.
yeah
and so
um oh go ahead
well I just want to
want to sing
um so yeah and about a year and a few
months
I've had just recently like we just had
this conversation like a couple of days
after I spent that email like end of
June
and like that was the first time
since all of this that I've like been
able to fully trust him for more than a
day okay
um and so
is is it because he's
if you take the pornography off the
table three different times you've said
this is an important value to me
and he has said I don't care
and so do you see how this is more about
trust than it is pornography
yes
pornography is is is the value
I want to be your only one
but the part that is rattling your body
is
I've told you what's important to me and
you've blown me off you've said your
needs are more important than mine and
when that's the case in a marriage the
boat sinks right
and so if you are at a place where you
say I'm going to trust him and by the
way trust is something you practice I'm
going all in
trust is a practice
and there's going to be mornings you
wake up and you suddenly you have a
Pang of this or a feeling of that or a
thought of this and you're going to have
to choose I'm going to trust him
until otherwise noted
so I mean
so the thing on that is like I
like this is the most I've trusted him
in a really long time but I'm scared to
like tell him that I trust him because
I'm scared to fully commit to that if
you don't you will suffocate yourself
and you will drown him
this is a marriage where you've got one
foot in and one foot out
you're playing married
and the problem is is pornography
alcohol working 98 hours a week I'm
convinced those are connection issues
and you start trying to heal that Gap or
duct tape over it or Band-Aid over that
gap of disconnection that you both feel
by the way
because he's married to a woman that has
never trusted him
and whether he acknowledges this
um
inside or he acknowledges it very
concretely
there's something he thinks is wrong
with him
because she won't trust me
and he might be untrustworthy just with
the pornography discussion you've shown
me him he's proven himself to be
untrustworthy
because he violated your values
see what I'm saying
yeah and so the conversation that needs
to happen with your marriage is are you
in are you out
and right now y'all are scuba diving and
you just have part of the of the snorkel
in
because you're afraid there's like
poison in the tank
and so what you're going to do is you're
going to guarantee that you suffocate
underwater
are you I mean you drown
by not wanting to breathe in the gas
and so what I would tell you is either
come to the surface or trust that
there's oxygen in the tank and breathe
it
is that fair
what's the do you trust you
um
I mean I I do more than I have
in the past like I
um
yes I think I think so maybe not
completely I just don't want to look
like an idiot if it happens again even
though I know like it has nothing to do
with me The Only Way Forward is
vulnerability and vulnerable is animals
rolling over and showing their bellies
and saying you could kill me
I'm asking you not to
yeah and I wish that wasn't the case
that's the only way relationships work
yeah and I'd like to think back that we
were that way but
I mean I guess not
well if it makes you feeling any better
I've had several times in my 20-year
marriage where I've had to do that
yeah I've had to check and I've realized
oh my gosh I'm not all in anymore
I'm partially in I'm playing a role
and then my wife feels it and then she
has to create a universe where she can
exist in it because I have all the
oxygen and I'm letting most of it go
underwater
see what I'm saying
and so the course of marriage is over
and over again every couple of years
every few weeks every decade
checking yourself and saying whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa I'm not all in anymore
I've made work my all in I've made
protecting my dignity My All In I have
made
not wanting to get burned my all
whatever the thing is I've made that My
All In
but when I got married to you I
committed to us being all in and so I'm
coming back and saying I'm sorry and I'm
going all in and by the way Samantha
you're well within your rights to say
I'm going all in
and if you violate my trust again I'm
going to go all out
see what I'm saying
yeah it's the middle ground that 95 of
couples except as normal
and you look around our culture of
lonely divorced broken up pornography
addicted alcohol addicted Netflix
addicted people who are just numbing
their way through a crappy miserable
life
yeah
it's a whole bunch of people scared to
go all in
and there's people who went all in and
got absolutely torched
foreign
I'll tell you that's the only way
forward
and I know that's scary
yeah but I feel more ready than I ever
have good so here's what that looks like
this is less about what I want and more
about what I need
okay
I would love for you to spend some time
with you just Samantha just by yourself
writing down here's what I need in this
marriage
I need somebody I trust
I need somebody that when I lay down a
value that they're with me on that
that we are wired together on values
and by the way when it comes something
like pornography
expect your husband to screw up
he may screw up
and that doesn't mean All Is Lost that
doesn't mean that's the end of
everything and it's a
if he comes to you and says hey I
screwed up
that's him making it right
if you check his search history a year
from now and all of a sudden you look at
this back then now we got a problem
because it's about the deception and the
lying right and it's the same if he says
hey I have a value that my wife my wife
is all in
that and it fill in the blanket right
this is about y'all creating a life
together
one that we can say we're all in on
and that means letting go of this false
security that you have that I'm going to
keep one toe out I'm going to keep one
I'm gonna keep myself chained to this
thing
and then I'm gonna jump off the edge
can't do it you got to just jump
and that's the beauty of relationships
you do it together
and the scary part is you can get hurt
let me put it this way you're gonna get
hurt
but man we all both going together the
beauty on either side of that thing is
something that the Alchemy of y'all two
working together it can be something so
much greater than you could have ever
ever imagined and for what it's worth
you're worth that
you're worth that